la feria del libro de Buenos Aires es
una abrumadora ciudad hecha de libros en
la que se pierden los lectores buscando
que comprar que leer a quién Escuchar
Con quién conversar durante unos días
los responsables de las bibliotecas
populares argentinas recorren los
pasillos Para aprovechar un programa que
les permite comprar a muy bajo precio
material para actualizar sus catálogos
y la mayoría son encargues de los
usuarios de los
de Los Socios y de los amigos de la
biblioteca tenemos un poquito de todo su
biblioteca existe hace 45 años y venir
aquí es para Andrea una tarea
indemnizable una vez a la familia deja
su trabajo
porque esto es más importante para
nosotros es la única forma de actualizar
la colección para los usuarios si bien
la compra de libros Es parte esencial de
esta feria También lo son los eventos
como la maratón de lectura dedicada a la
autora chilena Gabriela Mistral
la feria es la materialización de un
vínculo en el que los lectores le ponen
el cuerpo a su relación con los libros
con los textos con los autores un tipo
de práctica que se hace especialmente
evidente en encuentros como el diálogo
de escritoras y escritores de
latinoamérica donde las palabras se
levantan del papel para convertirse en
reflexiones compartidas reconocer el
caos como un material posible no el caos
como una forma de de habitar el mundo
caótico en Sí pero reconociéndolo como
parte de nuestra propia estructura de
nuestra propia esencia un caos vital del
que la feria del libro es ejemplo
patente con su multiplicidad de
actividades superpuestas cientos de
stands y miles y miles de visitantes